oh
come here
Travis Scott is daughter stormy science
teacher for the day
the father-daughter Duo is making some
sweet memories together and looks like
four-year-old stormy is a fast learner
amazing Travis's girlfriend and stormy's
Mom Kylie Jenner posted the cute moment
on Tick Tock the rapper shows the little
one how to create lava inside a volcano
First Step add food coloring to water
all right the water in there
all right
boy
what's it called when it's inside the
volcano
about what's it called
stormy through everything step by step
seems like stormy isn't the only one
practicing patience
[Music]
in the end scientist story pulls off a
perfect volcanic eruption
[Music]
seems like Kylie and Travis are keeping
things low-key at home just days after
the sicko mode rappers impromptu
performance in New York where things got
a bit out of control
[Applause]
[Music]
Travis abruptly stopping his concert at
the Coney Island art walls Independence
Day event due to safety concerns
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this surprise show comes one month
before the rapper is set to head out on
tour his first Major Performance after
the AstroWorld tragedy last November
where 10 people died and hundreds were
injured due to overcrowding I'm honestly
just devastated and I could never
imagine anything like this just
happening you know my fans my fans like
my fans really mean the world to me and
I always just really want to leave them
with a positive experience
I love it and we love to see the Webster
crew bonding online and in real life
[Music]
adorable outing at the 2022 Billboard
Music Awards where the couple brought
stormy along and she completely stole
the show
Trevor you enjoying your family night
out
Kylie are you enjoying Mom and Dad
nights out hi stormy
hi storm
how cute is she
[Music]